Voiceover: D. W. Griffith was the most
popular director of the silent era.
During the year 1913,
he made dozens of films.
One of the films that is most important
is "The Mothering Heart",
starring Lillian Gish.
She is a young bride
and is rather victorian.
She is trying to make her home comfortable
and pleasing for her husband.
At one point, she takes an
interest in baby clothes.
This is signaling to the
audience that she's pregnant.
Her husband is much more
interested in the life in the city.
(darker mood music)
Along the way, he meets what
is called an "idol lady",
a very well-dressed young
woman and they begin an affair.
He comes home and he is
obviously not satisfied
with the lack of sophistication
that his wife shows him.
What is really fascinating
about this film,
is the way Lillian Gish's
character transforms
into a modern woman.
She decides to leave,
which is a very bold move
for a young woman at that time.
She goes back to live with her mother
and has her baby.
The husband comes running back to Lillian
and she refuses to accept him.
Unlike the idol woman,
who has no sense of self,
she is really a cipher
to these men she meets.
Lillian Gish's character
finds this inner strength.
She loses her husband, but
what she does gain in this
is this personal integrity.
The cinema is no longer
just entertainment.
This is a way of learning.